- [Announcer] Legal Eagle is coming in
loud and clear, thanks to Ting Mobile.
- Let's take a break from the
ongoing impeachment dramas,
dramatic firings, and
Coronavirus pandemic,
and jump onto some good old
fashioned breaking lawsuit news.
As you may have heard,
one-time presidential hopeful
and current presidential
flameout Tulsi Gabbard,
is suing former presidential candidate
Hillary Clinton for defamation.
(loud boom)
It's finally happening people.
Tulsi Gabbard is an
ex-republican now serving
as the Democratic U.S. Representative
for Hawaii's Second
Congressional District.
Gabbard endorsed Bernie Sanders
during the 2016 Presidential election
and became a frequent guest on Fox News.
- [Reporter] Congresswoman,
thanks a lot for coming on.
- Thank you very much.
- Now of course, none of this endeared her
to Hillary Clinton.
For those of you just
joining us on planet earth,
Hillary Clinton is the former first lady,
former senator, former Secretary of State,
and loser in the 2016
Presidential election.
So Congresswoman Gabbard's
Presidential candidacy
stoked somewhat of a rivalry
between her and Hillary Clinton.
And in that process, Hillary Clinton
alluded to Tulsi Gabbard as
being a possible Russian agent.
As a result, Miss Gabbard
filed a defamation lawsuit
against Hillary Clinton.
This seems exactly like
the kind of reality show
dreamed up by one Donald J. Trump,
or maybe this guy, and possibly this guy,
because he definitely takes interest
in the opinions of women.
(dramatic orchestral music)
Hey legal eagles, it's time
to think like a lawyer,
because this is the lawsuit
that we've all been waiting for.
Now we will dig into the
details about defamation,
whether Congresswoman Gabbard
stands any chance at all
in this particular lawsuit,
but let's start with
the newest controversy about this lawsuit,
and that is potentially petty actions
taken by Hillary Clinton
to avoid the lawsuit
in the first place.
Now of course, the Gabbard
versus Clinton lawsuit
is a clickbait headline
writer's dream come true,
but the most recent clickable headline
involves Hillary Clinton allegedly
dodging service of process.
Now that sounds bad, right,
but let's talk about the
basics of filing a lawsuit,
because this is the stuff
that as a practicing lawyer,
I absolutely love to dig into.
You come for the drama on this channel,
and you stay for the mundane
facts about legal process.
What what can I say?
So a little background.
For a lawsuit to go forward,
you have to write the
complaint, which lays out
your own story, and file with the court.
Once you have filed the
complaint and the summons,
you have to actually give
that, usually physically,
to the defendant that you're going to sue.
This is called service of process,
and you can either serve the
defendant, him or herself,
or you can serve the person
who has been designated
to accept that service on
that defendant's behalf.
So, a corporation has to designate a agent
for service of process.
Now, Gabbard's attorneys
told The New York Post
that Hillary Clinton was
evading service of process,
so it actually prevented Gabbard
from going forward with this lawsuit.
Now according to Russia
Today which, you know,
take this with a grain of salt,
Clinton allegedly used the Secret Service
to deny the processor access to her home.
Russia Today also reported that Gabbard
tried to effect service at
Clinton's lawyer's office,
but the lawyer apparently
said he could not
accept the papers on her behalf,
and generally, that's true.
You have to actually designate
a specific agent to receive process.
You can't just serve a lawsuit
on any particular lawyer,
but as a practical matter,
often lawyers will just
accept the service of process,
assuming that their client has given them
authorization to do so.
Now Gabbard's lawyers
have yet to confirm this
in a filing with the court.
it's still very early in this process.
Not surprisingly,
Gabbard's lawyers expressed
mock disbelief the Clinton
would evade service,
saying, "I find it rather
unbelievable that Hillary Clinton
"is so intimidated by Tulsi Gabbard,
"that she won't accept
service of process."
He told the post, "but
I guess here we are."
Nobody wants to have a
court case go forward
without their participation in that case,
and the ability to defend oneself.
This is a constitutional requirement.
Due process requires that the
complaint be formally served,
or else the court might
not have jurisdiction,
or the ability to decide the
rights between the parties,
and it's not a particularly
onerous process, either.
Under Rule 4 of the Federal
Rules of Civil Procedure,
any person who is not
a party to the lawsuit,
may deliver the lawsuit
papers to the defendant.
That person has to be over 18 years old.
The plaintiff can use a process server,
or send someone else,
but it has to be someone
other than the plaintiff to the lawsuit
actually delivering the papers.
This prevents Tulsi
Gabbard from showing up
on Hillary's front door with a summons,
and a copy of her own complaint,
even though that would make for great TV.
Meanwhile the defendant can
receive the papers, him or herself.
Often, this results in TV,
where the process server
engages in some subterfuge
and delivers the paper,
and says you have been served.
I mean, you don't actually
have to say those words,
but that is sort of what
actually happens in real life.
Otherwise, the defendant can
just nominate some other person
to receive the service of
process on their behalf,
and in some circumstances the
lawsuit can also be served
by leaving it at the persons dwelling.
It can be left with a
person at the residence,
if the person is of a
suitable age and discretion.
Now in this particular case,
what Gabbard and her lawyers
are saying, is that Hillary
Clinton is aware of the lawsuit,
and she is purposefully evading service,
so that Gabbard can't go
forward with the lawsuit.
- What do you think will
happen in this lawsuit?
What's her response been so far?
- To my knowledge, we've
not gotten any kind of
official or unofficial response.
- In cases like this,
there's often a fine line
between evading service and
just simply not making it
as easy on the plaintiff as possible.
It's generally not a good
idea to evade service,
because the plaintiff will
be able to affect service,
eventually, and we'll talk
about how they do that,
but there's no requirement
that the defendant
make it easy on the plaintiff.
You might have a good reason for doing so.
You can often get more
time to answer a complaint,
if you just agree to accept service,
if you know it's out there,
but there's no requirement that you
actually make it easy for them.
So, this may be just a
case of tomato, tomato.
That what Gabbard is
saying, is evading service,
Hillary Clinton is just saying,
I'm not gonna make it easy for you,
and I have no requirement to do so.
And the same is generally
true of housekeepers,
and other support staff.
They've probably been
instructed not to accept
service of process unless their boss
explicitly authorizes it, and
as for the Secret Service,
it wouldn't be a shock to
me if they have a policy
of not accepting any mail or paperwork
on behalf of the people
that they're protecting.
They are, of course, there to protect
the political figure from
harm, not to do errands,
or chores for that political figure,
and accepting processes, is in effect,
something that inures to the
benefit of, in this case,
Hillary Clinton, but
even if Hillary Clinton
is evading service, she won't be able
to evade service forever.
The law gives Gabbard and her attorneys
plenty of other options, including having
the U.S. Marshals serve the papers.
Generally speaking, the
plaintiff has 120 days
after the filing of a
complaint to provide proof
that the lawsuit was properly served,
although you can get an
extension from the judge,
and if the plaintiff
fails to make service,
the defendant can file a motion
to dismiss the case for improper service.
As a last resort,
plaintiffs may ask the court
if they can serve the lawsuit
by publication or other means.
This is a method of service
that allows the plaintiff
to just published the details
of the lawsuit in a newspaper,
and this is often used when
the defendant can't be found,
or is intentionally evading service.
So Tulsi Gabbard filed her
lawsuit on January 25, 2020.
It hasn't even been 30
days yet, and I suspect
that this lawsuit will be
filed one way or another,
before the deadline runs in May.
But enough about the legal minutia
that perhaps only I care about.
Let's dig into the meat and potatoes
of Tulsi's defamation claim
against Hillary Clinton.
As you may know, defamation
is an area of law
that gives people a remedy
when someone says something
that is harmful to a person's
reputation or livelihood,
and that is, of course, false.
Traditionally defamation has been
divided up into two categories.
Written defamation, called
libel, that's L-I-B-E-L,
not liable, L-I-A-B-L-E, and slander,
which is spoken defamation.
But courts see no real
distinction between the two kinds,
and so it's gentlemen just
referred to as defamation.
In its most basic sense,
a statement is defamatory
if it tends to harm the
reputation of another,
as to lower him or her in the
estimation of the community,
or to deter third
persons from associating,
or dealing with him or her.
In other words, defamation
is making some statement
which takes a serious toll
on someone's reputation,
and therefore, causes them harm.
As you may already know, defamation suits
are particularly difficult to win.
That's because defamation law has evolved,
and as the Supreme Court has decided
more and more defamation
cases, that prima facie case,
a plaintiff must prove,
has gotten more specific
and far more challenging.
But prior to the mid-20th century,
a plaintiff in a defamation suit,
typically only had to prove
that a statement made by the defendant
was intentionally or
negligently published,
and that the remark defamed the plaintiff
in the minds of the recipients.
And as for the plaintiff,
doing so was pretty easy.
All you had to do was say,
hey, this guy called me
a lily livered loser, and I ain't one,
and bam, you could win
the defamation lawsuit.
However, a landmark Supreme Court case
changed defamation law forever,
making it harder to sue
and easier to practice
truly free speech, because you can imagine
in the prior example, that's
a recipe for stifling speech.
When the Supreme Court
decided the seminal case
of New York Times versus Sullivan,
the pendulum swung much
more towards the defendant,
and made it much harder for plaintiffs.
In that case the New York Times
published an advertisement
asking for donations to
defend Martin Luther King.
The ad criticized the police
in Montgomery, Alabama
for their actions during
the Civil Rights protest
in the city, and the ad contained
several minor factual inaccuracies,
such as misstating the number of times
that Dr. King was arrested.
Now the Montgomery Public
Safety Commissioner,
L.B. Sullivan, who was
not mentioned in the ad,
took it as a personal attack,
and he asked the Times
to retract the information,
and they refused.
Then Sullivan sued the New York Times,
and several African American protesters
under the Alabama libel law,
and he was actually able to
win a huge verdict at trial,
and as a result, the defendants appealed.
Eventually, the case went all the way up
to the US Supreme Court,
and the Supreme Court
issued a unanimous decision,
stating that the verdict
violated the First Amendment.
This decision is a notable
defense of freedom of the press.
Before the Sullivan case,
Southern politicians had filed
nearly $300 million in libel actions
against news organizations.
This was a coordinated effort
to use defamation lawsuits
to suppress coverage of police brutality,
discrimination, and the
civil rights movement,
but the court's decision
announced a new test
for defamation claims
involving public figures.
When allegedly defamatory statements
involve a public figure,
it's not enough to say that
they are false, and that they
were negligently published,
the public figure must also
prove that the statement
was made with what's called actual malice,
and actual malice, doesn't mean
they really hated this person.
It's a legal term of art.
It means that the speaker must
have known, actually known,
that the statement they
were making was false,
or that the person made that statement
with reckless disregard
for its truth, or falsity.
Those are much higher
standards than negligence,
and just simply not knowing
whether something is true or false.
The idea was that if public
figures could sue newspapers,
and citizens anytime that
they were criticized,
it would effectively silence criticism
and make government less transparent.
Now you've probably heard the statement
that truth is a defense to defamation,
and this refers to the law's requirement
that this statement a person
is complaining about must be false.
Now, why is that?
Because if the statement
is critical, but true,
it's not considered damaging,
or at least not the kind of damage
that we want the court system to remedy.
Under American law, and
this is not the case
throughout the world, you
can only sue for defamation
if something false is said about you.
True things that put
you in a negative light
aren't grounds for a defamation suit.
Now that's in regards to verifiable facts,
but free speech also gives you
the right to have opinions,
and to express them.
So opinions, which
there's no way to validate
one way or another, also are not subject
to a defamation suit, in
part because most opinions
cannot be objectively
proven true or false.
For example, Martin Scorsese
created an internet war
when he wrote an Op-Ed
in the New York Times
about why he didn't think
superhero movies are cinema,
and said that they're
closer to theme parks
than to actual movies.
Now, you may agree with him or not,
but that's not grounds for defamation,
even if it was particularized against
one particular person, or movie.
That's his opinion, he's
entitled to have it,
and he can say it without repercussions.
In other defamation cases,
the Supreme Court has found
statements to not be defamatory,
because even the most careless reader
must have perceived that the word
was no more than rhetorical hyperbole.
So, for example when Larry
Flynt and Penthouse Magazine
ran an article about Jerry Falwell
writing in the first person
about losing his virginity,
that wasn't defamation because
no one would have thought
it was actually Jerry
Falwell writing that article.
Often the curt reasons
that permitting hyperbole,
or satire, or parodies, that it encourages
an imaginative expression
in public debate.
In another fantastic
case that I am thrilled
to be able to share with you in public,
a newspaper article once
referred to a university official
as, quote, Director of Butt Licking,
and a Virginia court
wrote that the phrase,
Director of Butt Licking is no more
than rhetorical hyperbole.
The phrase is disgusting and offensive,
and in extremely bad taste,
but it cannot reasonably be understood
as stating in actual fact
about the official's job title,
or her conduct, or that she committed
a crime of moral turpitude.
So remember kids, you have
a constitutional right
to refer to your professor
as Professor Butt Licker,
but I would not recommend it.
So bottom line, here is
what you need to know
about defamation, because the
internet is full of people
that do not understand defamation.
Number one, a true statement that damages
someone's reputation is not defamation.
Two, an opinion is not defamation.
Three, a statement containing hyperbole
is usually not defamation.
Four, a public figure cannot
prove a false statement
is defamatory unless they prove the person
acted with actual malice.
And number five, and this is a big one,
and please if you take
anything away, remember this.
Actual malice doesn't mean
I wanted to hurt someone.
It means the person knew
that the statement was false,
or acted with reckless disregard,
for whether they knew it
was true or false, or not.
And that my friend is
a very high standard,
which is why you don't
see a lot of politicians
filing suits for defamation.
And generally, when you see
a politician file a suit
for defamation, it means they're a hack,
(loud boom)
an idiot, and they want to stifle speech.
Okay, breathe.
So, now that we've had a little
refresher on defamation law,
let's get back to the issue at hand,
(loud boom)
Gabbard versus Clinton.
In Gabbard's lawsuit, which
was filed in federal court
in New York, Gabbard
alleges that she suffered
at least $50 million in actual damages,
because of Clinton's comments,
allegedly about Gabbard,
on a podcast this past fall.
- [David] So, he's gonna
try and drive the people
not to vote for him, but just to say,
you know, you can't vote for them either,
and that seems to be,
I think to the extent
that I can define a strategy,
their key strategy right now.
- [Hillary] Well I think
there's gonna be two parts,
and I think it's gonna
be the same as 2016.
They're also gonna do third party again,
and I'm not making any predictions,
but I think they've got
their eye on somebody
who's currently in the Democratic primary,
and are grooming her to be
the third party candidate.
She's a favorite of the Russians.
They have a bunch of sites, and bots,
and other ways of supporting her so far,
and that's assuming Jill
Stein will give it up,
which she might not, 'cause
she's also a Russian asset.
- So let's break down Hillary
Clinton's comments here.
She says that Trump has his eye on someone
in the Democratic primary,
that is being groomed
to be a third party candidate.
This person is described as an asset,
or a favorite of the Russians.
This person is a beneficiary
of bots and sites
driving internet traffic,
amplifying this person's support.
Clinton speculates that Jill Stein,
the Green Party candidate who ran in 2016,
may also run for president again,
and described Stein as
also a Russian asset.
Although in the Russian asset context,
Clinton didn't mention Gabbard by name.
It's clear in context, that she's really
referring to Gabbard, and, in fact,
a spokesperson for Clinton
did confirm that the comment
was referring to
Congresswoman Gabbard herself.
In response, Tulsi Gabbard
denied any suggestion
that she might run as a
third party candidate,
and of course, she took to
Twitter calling Clinton,
"the queen of warmongers,
embodiment of corruption,
"and personification of the rot
"that has sickened the
Democratic Party for so long."
Gabbard also claims that
Clinton has had it out for her
for quite some time now,
referring back to her time
as the Vice Chair of the DNC during 2016,
and in her complaint Gabbard alleges
that Clinton was trying to derail
the congresswoman's campaign by advancing
a conspiracy theory that she is
associated with the Russians.
- For Hillary Clinton
and her powerful allies
to attempt to smear me, and accuse me,
really implying that I'm a traitor
to the country that I love,
is something that I cannot
allow to go unchecked.
I'm filing this lawsuit,
because I will not allow her,
or anyone, to try to intimidate me
or other patriotic Americans into silence.
- So here's the big question.
Will Gabbard win her suit
against Hillary Clinton?
No, no, she will not.
It is extraordinarily unlikely
that Gabbard will win her lawsuit,
even under pre-Sullivan law,
Gabbard would have a
really rough go of it,
even assuming that Clinton's statement
was intentionally made to
injure Gabbard's reputation,
she would still have to
prove that the statement
hurt her in the eyes of the public,
and that it was made with actual malice,
and also that it's untrue.
As you may have heard, one
reason people don't file
defamation suits is because
its subjects them to discovery,
and the defendant is allowed to probe
the truth or falsity of those allegations.
In order to win Gabbard
would have to show,
that Clinton made her statement
about involvement with the Russians,
even though she knew
that there was absolutely
no truth to this statement.
She'd also have to show
that it wasn't hyperbole,
it wasn't opinion, and that
it was a verifiable fact
that was disregarded false,
and that she can prove
Clinton knew it was
false, when she said it.
Hillary Clinton's comments
are fairly sloppy,
and that actually it might help
her in this particular case.
They mostly speculate about
what the Russians are doing.
She may be right about it or
she might be totally wrong,
and one problem for Gabbard is that
lots of people have speculated
that she's going to run as
a third party candidate,
potentially as a spoiler.
- We will stand together, and
we will unite this country
at a terribly divided time.
- It's not a fact that exists,
but would exist in the future.
So, it's not even a verifiable
fact in the present day,
and of course, Hillary Clinton can defend
on the basis that her statements
were opinion or hyperbole.
Arguably, Hillary Clinton was
employing extreme hyperbole
to insinuate that Tulsi was
serving Russian interests,
with her policy arguments.
Not that Tulsi Gabbard was
actually spying for Russia,
and Hillary Clinton could also
probably defend on the basis
that her statements were factually true.
If we look back at one of Clinton's
statements about Gabbard, she says,
"She's a favorite of the
Russians, they have a bunch
"of sites of bots and other
ways of supporting her."
Now back in February of
2019, before Tulsi Gabbard
formally announced her
presidential candidacy,
NBC News reported the following.
"An NBC News analysis of
the main English-language
"news sites employed by
Russia in its 2016 election
"meddling shows Representative
Tulsi Gabbard of Hawaii,
"who was set to make her
formal announcement Saturday,
"has become a favorite
of the sites Moscow used
"when it interfered in 2016."
The news report pointed to 20 stories
on Russian-language websites,
which are affiliated with
the Putin government,
including Russia Today, and Sputnik,
which the CIA describes
as part of the quote,
Russia's state run propaganda machine.
Now, I'm not saying
Gabbard is a Russian asset.
In fact, there isn't
even a firm definition
of what asset means in this context.
By most accounts, a Russian agent
is a specific term denoting a spy,
but an asset is usually
defined as a useful
or valuable thing, person, or quality.
Is Hillary Clinton
saying that Tulsi Gabbard
is a Russian spy, or is she
saying that she is useful
to the Russians agenda,
whether intentionally or not.
Probably the latter,
and is that defamatory?
I don't think so, and finally,
although you might think
that Donald Trump, or Hillary
Clinton, or Tulsi Gabbard
invented political
insults and mean tweets.
The historical record shows
that insults in politics
are really an American tradition.
For example, John Adams did not think
history has its eyes
on Alexander Hamilton.
He once said, "I lose all
patience when I think of that
"bastard brat of a Scottish peddler."
and good old Adams also
didn't love Thomas Jefferson.
A quote, "mean spirited, low-lived fellow,
the son of a half-breed Indian squaw,
"sired by a Virginia mulatto father."
And U.S. Interior Secretary Harold Ickes
once attacks Louisiana
Senator Huey Long as, quote,
"suffering from halitosis
of the intellect,
"that's presuming he has an intellect."
So, it's probably not the
case that Tulsi Gabbard
is coordinating her presidential
campaign with Russia.
So, Hillary Clinton's
insults against Tulsi Gabbard
are nothing unusual, they're firmly rooted
in the American tradition, and
it's probably pretty unlikely
that Gabbard is coordinating
her presidential campaign
with Russia, but if she were
coordinating with Russia,
she should really try to
save on her cell phone bill,
because calling Moscow can
be really, really expensive.
So, I would recommend that Tulsi Gabbard
check out ting mobile Ting Mobile.
Ting Mobile is a different
kind of mobile provider.
With Ting you only pay for
your actual data and services
that you use at the end of the month,
and because you're only
paying for what you use,
Ting customers pay on average,
just $23 per month for one device,
and there's no contract, overage fees,
or any other carrier tricks.
You just pay a fair price
for the top text and data
that you use up every month,
and Ting has award
winning customer service.
Because they don't have any
brick and mortar stores,
they pour their resources
into phone support.
If you have an issue, give them a call,
and you'll immediately
talk to a real human,
and if you're like me,
and you want to avoid
talking to any human being,
they also offer support
through chat, email,
social media and even Discord,
which my fellow kids say is totes yeet yo.
I'm just kidding, I swear
I'll start a Discord server,
at some point, I'll get
around to it eventually.
But with Ting, you can
use almost any cell phone,
including the newest iPhones
and Google Pixel phones,
and you can use the same phone number
that you're using right now.
Ting provides great LTE coverage,
because it uses both the
T-Mobile and Sprint network,
so regardless of whether
the FTC allows them
to merge or not, you can
get the best of both worlds.
With Ting, especially if you
are around Wi-Fi all the time,
which most of us are,
really, you'll end up paying
way less than you do now.
Yes, some people should pay
$200 a month for unlimited data,
but if you're surrounded by Wi-Fi all day,
then you don't need
cell data all day long,
and you might be paying
hundreds of dollars per month,
completely unnecessarily,
and Ting gives you
the option to pay for only what you use.
So if you go to LegalEagle.Ting.com,
you can use their tool to
compare your last cell phone bill
to what you would pay
with Ting if you switched,
and Legal Eagles will get a $25 credit
by going to LegalEagle.Ting.com,
and that $25 credit
could cover your entire
first month of cell phone usage,
and since there are no contracts,
you can try it for a
month, no strings attached.
Again, all you have to
do is click the link
in the description, or go
to LegalEagle.Ting.com,
and get a $25 credit for
whatever service you want.
Plus, clicking on the link,
really helps out this channel.
So, do you agree with my analysis?
Leave your objections in the comments,
and check out this playlist over here,
with all of my other Real Law Reviews
of other legal current events.
Just click on this playlist,
and I'll see you in court.